[Applause]
[Music]
oh it's going in and out of my ear i
don't give a damn
all right happy post thanksgiving friday
i hope you feel as fat as i do
oh i'm filled with gravy and
self-loathing to the monologue shall we
so he lied about helping a homeless vet
and now must pay a big old debt it was a
kind gesture anyone could applaud but it
turned out to be a giant fraud yeah this
week in new jersey man aren't they all
pleaded guilty to conspiracy to commit
wire fraud and a case that captivated
the country actually it captivated a
naive media who will believe anything
that matches their assumptions but if
any of you heard this story you knew it
was as fake as kim kardashian's butt
or half of her
butt back in 2017 mark d'amico
and his ex-girlfriend cooked up an
entire story to raise money for a
homeless guy using gofundme the same
site that shut down the written house
defense fund if you like to keep track
d'amico claimed the down on his luck
veteran johnny bobbitt jr
an unfortunate name gave them his last
20 bucks for gas
see the homeless guy gave him gas they
then started a gofundme campaign to pay
it forward and raise money to get the
veteran off the streets it's kind of
like what joe did for hunter in china
so of course media outlets picked up the
story and they covered it like the
heartwarming tale it seemed to be
an act of kindness from a homeless
veteran that is now getting national
attention yeah this is a feel-good story
what if we started a gofundme for the
scott we set it up in the car
on the way home you're going from zero
literally
to 300 and some odd thousand dollars
it's like winning the lottery johnny
bobbitt was down on his luck but this
morning after one random act of kindness
thousands of people are pitching in to
help the homeless veteran with a heart
of gold a homeless veteran living on the
streets in philadelphia teaching an
entire nation about what it means to
give
anyway it wasn't true it turned out to
be as heartwarming as a stent filled
with hot bacon grease
yep like the nigerian prince who said he
wanted to marry me and give me a dowry
of 25 million bucks the story was too
good to be true
i flew to meet him in amsterdam
stood me up and i had a hell of a time
getting those goats back through customs
well turns out they made it all up and
defrauded more than 14 000 donors out of
400 000 bucks money that bankrolled
their vacations the new bmw clothes and
other stuff possibly a hundred biden
painting or two
meanwhile bobbitt was back on the
streets and only saw a fraction of the
money they raised turns out gofundme
became go for herself
back in 2019 the ex-girlfriend and the
homeless guy pleaded guilty to
conspiracy to commit wire fraud for
their involvement and are awaiting
sentencing
well he won't be he won't be homeless
then i guess
three meals
as for dimiko or whatever the hell his
name is he's facing 20 years in prison
and a 250 000 fine and probably a job at
cnn when he gets out
where pushing hoaxes is the profit model
no matter how many people it harms so
what is the lesson here that if a story
is too much on the nose
it's probably complete crap
back when this story came up we did it
as a one more thing on the five which
meant we probably didn't look at it that
closely we were too busy combing
geraldo's mustache
that takes at least four hours and 12
men
sounds like a weekend
but we live in a media landscape where
if someone wants a story to be real they
will assume it's real every story is
driven by a false narrative born from a
journalist who feels good telling it it
could have been the covington kid the
kavanaugh hearings the story of kyle
rittenhouse fact is there are no facts
anymore when stories are told the steele
dossier captivated a whole slew of
cognitively biased idiots and even as
the facts kept falling apart they clung
to it like stelter on a donut
they wanted so badly to believe hookers
peed on trump that they were happy to
poop on the truth
and yet it was the american public who
got stuck with the dirty laundry
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
he's so handsome he turns semper fi into
semper fine
retired u.s marine corps bomb technician
and fox news contributor johnny joey
jones
when he performs on cruise ships they
aim for the icebergs
comedian joe mackey
he's going to turn black friday into
blackout friday buster's contributor tim
and his shoe size is mayflower my
massive side taking host of nutsed on
fox nation tyrant
so joey as a veteran does this offend
you that they actually i mean it's such
a it's such an insulting story in a way
that it's like the story is based on the
fact that no homeless guy would ever
give you 20 bucks but this homeless guy
did and he's a veteran i mean he was
like so crafted
listen it
not only is a story
but it's like smells of number one if a
veteran walks up to a woman that's that
like forgot to put gas in her car and
can't get home he's going to give her a
lecture it doesn't matter if he's got
money or homeless or not he's going to
explain to her about all the ways she
screwed her life up to literally not
have money to put gas in her car to get
home he's going to say you know what i
know this problem exists that's why i
don't have a car or a home i fixed this
problem before i ever had this problem
and you should too maybe you should
consider leaving this car here and
living in my tent over there that's what
a veteran is going to say that's true
but really like what's really funny
about this is if i gave money to this
cause all i would want is for the bo the
bobbit guy to like keep his 20 year old
truck in the trailer they gave him to
live in like that is hilarious yeah like
yeah he got a veteran's dream he's
living in a trailer and he's got a truck
like what else could you want like i
want the guy to have it yeah you know
what i mean they took advantage of him
joe now when you when you heard this
story mackie um or maybe you didn't hear
this story because you're too busy doing
drugs it's some weird orgy
uh but listen
about the the people that brought this
guy in and interviewed him i'm sorry
this is important there's a whole
government agency that you can write an
email and find out if somebody's a
veteran like at least that part but he
might have been a veteran i don't know i
think he might i should write that email
yes well now i'm worried
just cut that part out okay joe what do
you think
well i'm glad you bailed me out of that
orgy
explanation
i'm sorry that was right i had no i had
nowhere to go with it
my private life i like to keep privacy
and i would appreciate it that going
forward we we respect that
i'll tell you what i think
when you have stories that i think are
intentionally wrong
uh that happens all the time in media
and then you have some stories that i
think uh
it's not that they didn't get duped it's
that they they didn't uh really do the
work right uh just like uh
like i got duped you know when they said
when you have your tonsils out you get
to eat all the ice cream yes you want
but ice cream hurts my teeth so
it doesn't feel good on a hole in your
throat
and i think what's happening here is you
have some some local journalists they
don't get paid that well their stories
are used for free on social media they
get to keep all the ad revenue so people
are pressed for time they don't have
time to check the facts and then
basically when the national news get
hears a feel-good story they click three
tweet button they don't do any due
diligence themselves and that's why i
don't trust any any good news i only
like i only like bad news yes
because all bad news is real
that's true it's a tough world greg yeah
yeah yeah hard to make a fake obituary
i've tried
tyrus
i i just the the hypocrisy kills me i
mean yeah they were wrong but that's
that's nothing different than just you
you mentioned the dossier right yeah
yeah how many democratic politicians ran
on we're gonna get him yeah we're gonna
do these things yeah and how many people
sent checks believing that this was true
they kept all that money they profited
from it they bought houses with it they
vacationed with it and then we found out
it was a lie
they just said well it was my truth at
the time right so what is the but
but a ra regular americans do it and
they're wrong for doing it but they got
to go to jail for 22 years and be
publicly shamed and republican and a
politician can just
run again right of course
it's ridiculous that
why are we so mad at them this is what
our government yeah you're right adam
schiff did this every single day and
they got called on and he was like well
you're gonna have to wait for my movie
to come out because i use the funds to
write my script for my manuscript for my
new movie that's actually true like
there's nothing like this compares to
the five years of that or any of this
stuff that's how many dollars in life
were ruined based off those lies yeah
exactly this reminds me though kind of
like this is like the opposite of a hate
crime hoax
hey i hate crime hoax they that tickles
or that ticks the box of certain news
people this did the same thing but it
was like this was a love hoax yeah and
in a way they really complimented the
homeless community yes because this guy
really was homeless and they really were
giving him some money but they kept more
for themselves because they're counting
you know if he says something
he's going to get in trouble too so they
counted on this homeless drug addict to
not do anything erratic yes
they respected the man how did he did
anybody read far enough in this article
to find out how they got caught because
he said something yes they were taking
helicopter rides on the grand canyon
they were not inviting the bum yeah
he got yeah
he got greedy
he got greedy they okay so they brought
they brought in like 400 grand he got
and i couldn't tell if it was 75 000
total to include yeah but they they
specified 19 year old truck in a trailer
to live in and it's like he spent some
of it on drugs because of course he did
yes that's probably all he wanted that's
what's great about the story that it's
not like i'm going back to what joey's
saying struck in a bunch of drugs it's
not a bad life but don't judge me for
saying that he wanted on the helicopter
yeah exactly he wanted to see his
trailer he wanted to go look i could see
my trailer from here
oh we thought you just wanted to be high
we didn't know you meant in a helicopter
like i'm sorry i'm so sorry here's
another team i would take the drugs over
the helicopter they were buying luxury
handbags they did not buy one for him no
they
didn't
all right i think we solved nothing no
but it felt good
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else